hallo mein name zu kommen meine lieben
freunde herzlich willkommen hier heute
zu einem neuen handy offen einem kanal
ihr hört ist bereits im hintergrund und
zwar richtig ostern durch den den
bernern deinen kopf schon in einigen
tagen ist der erste dezember und dieses
jahr liegt der erste dezember sogar auf
dem ersten advent das heißt die
weihnachtszeit geht los und wisst ihr
was übrigens auch am ersten dezember
passiert richtig
apropos dick und doof wo die soeben ist
eine neue folge unseres podcasts dick
und doof online gegangen also schaut
kennen die infobox essen link allerdings
meine lieben freunde die weihnachtszeit
steht auch für shopping
es gibt unfassbar viele krasse angebote
et cetera pp und unter anderem gibt es
auch den black friday der ist nämlich
morgen gibt es immer besonders krasse
angebote einer lieben freundin die heute
gemeinsam das spiel christopher zeller 2
black friday
ich würde sagen wir stützen uns direkt
ins game nächst einmal können wir uns
hier eine person aus will mit der wir
spielen wollen nämlich würde sagen wir
nehmen diese typen 27 november 2015
black friday also es ist black friday
the mall wo laufen drei zwei eins und
los also das ist happy black friday wir
können ja jetzt reinlaufen mit den schon
das spiel ruckelt überhaupt nicht ob
verbissen ist die erste challenge haben
wir komplett also wir sind in die halle
rein gelaufen
das wichtigste ist jetzt dass wir so
viele gegenstände wie möglich uns
irgendwie krallen und kaufen was wir uns
dann
was holen wir uns denn ich kann ich kann
ich kann leute treten
das ist ja fast wieder richtige black
friday hier schießt einer allerdings
sehen wir schon unten rechts unsere
challenge gerade eingeblendet und zwar
and change in trossingen also wir sollen
in einen bestimmten laden reihen laufen
hier ist chefin trafiken das heißt wenn
ich hier rein laufe hh challenge
complete edition die braut das hier
haha ich bin gar so beschissen
warum tanzen die hier alle keine ahnung
was in diesem laden hier abgeht
die tanzen auf jeden fall alle ziemlich
heftig ich musste jetzt allerdings
kaufen und ich habe einen report
ich wusste nicht dass das spiel so krass
komplex ist ich würde allerdings sagen
unser komischer ice cream sandwich man
läuft hier mal wieder raus und die ich
bin hingefallen
wegen dem vollidioten der weg hatte wir
schmeißen direkt auf der mall raus ich
meine jetzt kann er nicht sein dass er
hier so viel gewalt irgendwie am start
ich habe ihn auf den eis stand gekickt
black friday halt aber gut ich meine wo
ich das video hier gerade hoch lage ist
donnerstag also es ist gar nicht so
richtig black friday allerdings apropos
black friday morgen im luca service auf
black friday ganz ganz ganz ganz viele
produkte sind auf jeden fall morgen im
luca - shop.de reduziert
da könnt ihr gerne ja einfach mal
vorbeischauen das geht von heute nacht 0
uhr bis morgen 8 0 uhr also morgen am
freitag gegen die alle 24 stunden lang
haben
hier ist ein eisberg in der mall es das
ist halt wirklich alles irgendwie wie in
amerika hier so viel krasser und größer
als alles in deutschland lebende lieben
freunde schaut gerne morgen im lukas ott
vorbei wenn ihr da irgend etwas
günstiger schießen wollte der hu die
idee nicht allerdings an habe der kommt
erst am 11 12
in den shows allerdings beschäftigen wir
uns jetzt wieder mit dem christmas
shopping sie mich laufen einfach mal an
der schlange vorbei jugendleiters rede
alle warten müsste ich will allerdings
hier hoch und was das ist der
weihnachtsmann kann ich theoretisch ich
hab den weihnachtsmann von seinem
derzeit mir auch den mittelfinger gerade
also ich habe keine ahnung was sie mit
dem weihnachtsmann abgeben
der weiter zwei und seinem eisberge
kickt jetzt liegt dieses sandwich
verkrüppelt auf boden allerdings würde
ich sagen dass wir uns mal wieder unsere
aufgaben kümmern und zwar vor meinem sf
tv box at evn carey okay wir sind direkt
vor tv & carry die messe team die box
hier ist schon hier ist schon alles
abgegrast vielleicht ist es dass wir
vorne das ist dass das ist ein subwoofer
den brauche ich nicht was haben wir denn
hier vorne noch rum liegen wir haben
hier eigentlich gar keinem sf tv box war
bin ich doch das oder ist das hier im
moment jemand hin das ding ist ich habe
auch nur 70 11 und gerade
ich will dass kaufen ja ich glaube
tatsächlich dass nicht mehr geld brauche
allerdings habe ich absolut kein plan wo
ich das geld herbekommen ich rede hier
einfach mal hoch wir sind jetzt schon im
letzten stockwerk hier oben ist essen
und so das ist ja auch immer so das ding
bei so molzen packen alles was man am
meisten eigentlich braucht nach ganz
oben bzw ans letzte ende
damit man auch schön an allen geschäften
der herr läuft also die taktiken da so
echt krass die frage ist jetzt wirklich
wie ich an geld komme ich kann nur
schauen nicht immer dem gnocchi laden
vielleicht kann ich ja hier fragen ob
ich irgendwie arbeiten kann so ein
bisschen hallo kann ich was macht der
typ hat eine box spielt damit die ganze
zeit was ist seine mission jetzt steht
er auf dem vorschlag
er schaut mich an hat er schon wieder
weg
er schaut mich gar nicht an seinen
hocker dreht sich einfach verliert
wieder daher läuft wieder zurück als
gläubiger was ich würde sagen du
verrückter typ du ich krieg dich einfach
mal weg
wir haben sogar glasbrechen animationen
dass er super
holt er sich jetzt wieder solche box im
kreis wir können aber die polizei fragen
ob er weiß irgendwie was ich hier an
geld für aussage ich wollte ich nicht
anderen können jetzt redet er mir den
rücken schießt ein ernst egal wir müssen
auf jeden fall irgendwie an geld kommen
und ich weiß nicht wie ich klicke mal
wieder was was packten hier vorne schon
wieder rum
nee gar nicht dass man oft entfernung
was haben wir hier vorne liegen lee
fried chicken okay also nicht kentucky
fried chicken
hier sind auch wieder so komische
menschen sie verlässt den laden wo
geht's hin hatte wir verfolgen die
beiden höhere wenige minuten später also
dass jetzt die frau aus diesen liege
lief fried chicken vorhin die steht er
jetzt einfach so rum und telefoniert und
jetzt hält sie das für sie ich mache
doch gar nicht die ganze zeit aber würde
ich meine wir müssen ja immer noch uns
diesen tv laden tv screen whatever
kaufen das heißt ich gehe immer wieder
rein
die sache ist allerdings dass sie ja gar
nicht mehr diesen tv screen haben soll
das könnte ja sein dass ist diesem sf tv
box hat im moment nicht optimal hier
drauf auf mein anderes ding you cannot
afford der seite mit costa hunde aber
genau ich hinterlegt das aber hier
einfach mal bei dir dass das nicht
irgendein anderer menschen irgendwie
noch kaufen ist das ok
ja sehe ich genauso allerdings haben
halt wirklich immer noch das geldproblem
ich weiß nicht ob wir aus der dings
einfach mal hier ist so ach hier kann
man die karte zu laufen dieses spiel ist
halt voll am ruckeln das ist voll war
die eigentlich aber eigentlich macht es
wirklich spaß für so ein kleines
bescheidenes spiel vielleicht kann man
irgendwo zu einem bankautomaten gehen
oder wir brechen ein auto ein
es geht auch nicht
wo sind wir eigentlich recht einfach mal
zu der hüpfburg hier vorne hin
hüpft man dann wirklich alter das ist ja
wahnsinn wir gehen weil hier zum als
laden also vielleicht kann ich mir
wenigstens ein eis kaufen was es ich
frage mich was denn überhaupt los mit
den beiden autos so packt man definitiv
richtig ein hier steht einfach ganz
allein eine person beziehungsweise ein
kleiner junge oder so steht hier rum und
telefoniert wieder ohne handy in der
hand
dk was ist mit dir los ist dass seine
oma da vorne die hier ankommt kümmert
die dich die sicherungen um dich oder
nötig das ist ja wie im horrorfilm
ich wollte ich wollte eigentlich nur zu
diesem jungen wenn das gewollt ist als
er ich habe auch noch mal angst das ist
dann guckt euch weiter dieses mädchen ja
die steht hier so rum und ihr kopf ist
einfach abgeknickt
die sind richtig gewesen frischer neue
service gestartet ja aber ich habe keine
ahnung was mit diesen medien hier los
ist höchstwahrscheinlich gar nicht wahr
sein dieses spiel nicht wahr ich nicht
anders märz ein lustiges geweiht
schwierigen aber nein das ist ja europa
hätte ich kotze bestrahlt jedes mal weg
von diesem mädchen
[Musik]
wollt ihr mich verarschen
das ist nicht wahr ich bewege mich jetzt
ganz langsam von diesem mädchen weg und
ich schaue das mädchen so lange an bis
ich kann nicht weiter nach hinten laufen
aber ich will mich auch nicht umdrehen
warte ich drehe mich jetzt weg von dem
mädchen okay
sie ist weg ok meine damen und herren
ich würde sagen wir hoffen aber
[Musik]
versuchen mit ihr zu reden ich gehe
jetzt einfach mal zu den grünen hin und
versuchen bisschen mit ihr zu reden gibt
es eine reden taste
dass gerade hier beschreibt eigentlich
das komplette video ich weiß auch nicht
ob ich da irgendwie wegtreten kann also
ich drücke einfach mal in die kuba das
sollte so sein
oh mein gott ich bin ja bla 20 ich
dachte erst irgendwie dass das ein
grafikfehler sei mit diesem komischen
creepy mädchen das wenn ich mich halt um
bringen dass sie genau man dahin kommt
wo ich mich hin gedreht habe aber sollte
anscheinend zu sein und war eine
challenge also durch die challenges
verdiene ich geld das heißt ich nehme
jetzt meinen fernseher und packen ihren
ich habe den fernseher gekauft und wir
haben immer noch solch für meine
freundin noch was kaufen alltag
das mache ich im zweiten teil wenn ihr
da bock drauf habe und wenn ich da bock
drauf hat meine lieben freunde dallas
auf jeden fall einen daumen hoch unter
dem video hier da schreibt mir gern mal
unten in die kommentare ob ihr morgen so
richtig shoppen werdet also viele
freunde von mir haben schon gesagt
dicker black friday juckt mich in furth
ich würde eigentlich ganz neues weil es
so viele dinge gibt die man sich
wirklich kaufen möchte allerdings
eventuell zu teuer waren gibt es dort
hat einfach reduziert zu krasseren
preisen zu günstigeren preisen einem so
auch in lucka job also schaut auf jeden
fall noch gerne im luca - shop.de vorbei
heute nacht 0 uhr geht's los und dann
morgen den ganzen tag 24 stunden lang
viele klamotten sind reduziert haben
prozent schaut gern vorbei dieser wurde
hier der exklusive und limitierte dick
und doof
die kommt am ersten zwölf der sind in
lucka shop da müssen noch ein paar tage
gedulden aber nicht gerne einen kanal
verschlag ein teil der luke rückseitig
sehen wir das voll viele sich meine
videos anschauen aber gar nicht abonnent
sind also tschüss dort geist und ich
würde jetzt einfach nur noch sagen
[Musik]